the head coach of the San Antonio Spurs
has a lot to say about your arms this
this was a comment he made on Sunday I'm
glad we can finally get to it here at
the it's been a very very busy week but
I'm glad we can get to it because it's
an important comment that this guy very
ignorantly made Greg Popovich suggested
that second amendment freedoms are a
myth on the way it goes to my mind that
I hope
they're going to be okay
and most of you in this room when we
were in school we worried if
Nancy would dance with us on Friday
after the football game or something
that was that was our anxiety
but they're going to cloak all this
stuff you know the second the myth of
the Second Amendment the freedom you
know it's just it's a myth it's a joke
it's it's just a game they play
I mean that's freedom is it freedom for
kids to go to school and try to
socialize and try to learn and be scared
to death that they might die that day
with Ted Cruz will fix him because he's
going to double the number of cops into
schools that's what he wants to do well
that'll create a great environment is
that freedom
or is it freedom to have a congressman
who can make a postcard with all his
family holding rifles including AR-15 or
whatever is that cool
so this coach is just obviously a
complete NPC this guy hasn't given two
seconds thought to the Second Amendment
to Firearms to the natural right to
self-protection he is just reciting all
the silly platitudes that you hear from
the libs and it's not his fault he
probably doesn't think about politics
very much so if he's got CNN on in the
background that's just what goes into
his head and that's what comes at his
mouth and there's a very little
conscious thought going on in between
those two things
but he makes one good point here
which is he says the Second Amendment of
freedoms that's a myth
it is a myth that's true it happens to
be a true myth it happens to be a myth
that tells a story that speaks to a real
truth which is your right to
self-protection but we tell it in the
form of stories and it's embedded within
our history and we see it in our legal
documents and unfortunately what the
Liberals have done in our modern era is
they have
demystified the world we're so damn
disenchanted we just look around the
world it's like Hamlet he looks out he
says I've I've lost all my Mirth
what a piece of work as a man you know
what what look at the sterile Promontory
this this Brave or hanging firmament
fretted with a golden fire it just it
seems to me no other thing than a
sterile Promontory then the man is this
quintessence of dust what what
Shakespeare was seeing occur in our
culture is what has totally come to
fruition now which is we just live in
this disenchanted world we need more
myth in the world we need more narrative
we need to recognize that we're not just
bags of chemicals but we are characters
in a story and just because something is
a myth doesn't mean it isn't true
there's a lot of chatter in Washington
DC right now about whether or not some
of the older members of the Senate are
going to move along Senator Dianne
Feinstein one of the
Democrats who is of a certain age as she
has not been in Washington in a while
she's been recuperating from an illness
there's question about whether she'll
ever get back to the Senate because she
is rather aged and then Mitch McConnell
as well Mitch McConnell suffered some
kind of an incident that has kept him
out of Washington there's been some talk
about Republicans preparing for Mitch
McConnell's replacement and the
McConnell office wants to Tamp that down
they say quote I am looking forward to
returning to the Senate on Monday we've
got important business to tackle and big
fights to win for kentuckians and the
American people
so this after he tripped and fell during
a dinner he says I'm not going anywhere
folks and I have to tell you
that's fine by me I am not a Mitch
McConnell hater I know he's not the most
conservative guy in the world I know
he's had all sorts of fights with
conservatives in the Senate
but you've got to respect the man for
his ability to wield power and sometimes
we wish that he would wield power for
more of the causes that we care about
but this guy understands the levers of
power in the Senate like nobody else and
I think conservatives all have to be
very grateful to McConnell because he
held up scalia's seat in the Supreme
Court and gave us a conservative judge
after Trump was elected and got Roe v
Wade overturned so I'm not a big
McConnell hater I respect the ability
that he has to wield that kind of power
and he shows a fact of especially the
Washington DC politicians which is they
they will cling to power until their
dying breath
Joe Biden is not going anywhere Joe
Biden
is not even a boomer Joe Biden is from
the generation before the Boomers which
is incredible to think that we went from
Bill Clinton first Boomer president to
George W bush first Boomer president to
Barack Obama is he Boomer or is he Gen X
I think he's a boomer
see well he's younger than the two other
guys and then then we went to Trump
Boomer president
and then
we went
to Biden who was older than all of the
previous ones this generation of
politicians does not want to give up
power the only thing that is going to
take them away from power is old father
time and the Grim Reaper coming and
pulling them out of office which means
that we are on the cusp of a sea change
but it's not happening gradually it's
not just the the older generation
preparing the way and opening the doors
for the younger people this is going to
happen rather suddenly so one of the
younger guys who is trying to grab hold
of some of that power is of course Ron
DeSantis
and in service of the presidential
campaign that he hasn't declared yet
Governor DeSantis has just signed the
heartbeat protection act into law late
Thursday night prohibits abortions in
the state once an unborn child has a
detectable heartbeat the squishes are
Furious about this the libs are mocking
the Santas they're saying he's he's
adopting unpopular positions that'll
harm him in the general election if he
becomes the nominee
one good on Governor DeSantis for
signing this bill
good let we just we need to take every
Victory we possibly can for the cause of
life the right to life is not just one
right among many it is the fundamental
right from which all the other rights
derive and we kill some 800 000 babies a
year in this country it is worse than
any genocide that that we've ever seen
other than China I guess kills more
people kills more babies through
abortion it it would make the Aztecs
blush it would make those ancient Middle
Eastern tribes who sacrificed their
children to moloch it would make them
blush the number of babies that were
killing so in itself this is the right
thing for DeSantis to do but I think
it's also a good political move not just
for the primary but for the general
election this is where the squishes
totally lose me because they read a
bunch of stupid public opinion polls and
they they realize that opinion is split
on abortion and they fear that anyone
having any courage of their convictions
is going to harm them in the general
election I don't think that's true
people are persuadable by Logic people
are persuadable by conviction it's
actually the squishes who aren't very
persuasive because they don't make any
compelling argument for anything
but on this issue don't forget the two
issues where conservatives have won over
the last 50 years it's guns and abortion
coincidentally those are the only issues
where conservatives have spoken with
Clarity so good on DeSantis
good on DeSantis for doing the right
thing but also going to understand this
for doing the thing that will help his
campaign in the primary and it might
even help his campaign should he make it
to the general election producer Colton
has brought me my iPad so I get to chat
with you in the membrane segment room
which begins now head on over to
dailywire.com Knowles I will need your
help to ascertain which of the headlines
are fake which of them are real
dailywire.com Knowles use code notes
you'll get two months free on all annual
plans
[Music]
oh
foreign